[Music]
open-wheel racing dominated the American
auto sports scene for decades really up
into the mid 1990s 1996 which is now
known as the split kart top series at
the time now has to face rival Indy
Racing League started by Tony George
bans checked out they didn't know which
series are supposed to watch sponsors
walked away cart eventually goes
bankrupt Indy Racing League is
hemorrhaging money the sport really just
falls apart this creates this vacuum
NASCAR Rises once a kind of southern
race saying really regional sport is now
the top auto sports racing series by the
early 2000s where as you know the Indy
500 had previously been the top race of
the year it now has one third of the
Daytona 500s viewership every year and
then you know open-wheel racing
continued to struggle the two sides were
unified in 2008 but things didn't get
better for a while it was unclear if
anyone would be able to turn around
IndyCar so then in late 2012 IndyCar
taps mark miles board member of the
parent company of the series to come in
take over a CEO and start trying to turn
around this series that was once you
know really an American icon generally
speaking for live sports in this country
especially network broadcast of sports
they've declined so I don't think we've
declined more than the norms but we
think that's an opportunity
everything we've done is aimed at
reversing that and beginning to inclined
back up the media ratings for the 500
I've been in the sport for quite some
time now and I've I've seen it's its
heyday I've seen its lowest day and
currently we are on a great path you
know it's been through a lot of hard
work through a lot of momentum over the
years but now here we are in 2019 with
the most competitive form of racing in
the world people are starting to to come
back to the Indianapolis 500 they're
starting to remember what made the race
and what made this series be so special
formerly the schedule ran into October
and the season was competing with
college football and the NFL I always
moved the end of the season up miles
also got rid of the double headers miles
realized they need to be in as many
markets as possible if you want to reach
fans and get new fans are gonna come
into the sport you need to really spread
out sports reach into those markets
we're adding new races to the calendar
we had Portland last year Laguna Seca
this year so everything really is going
in the direction that you want it to be
in and to be able to be a part of that
as a driver has been very cool to
witness series also made investments
I've been almost a hundred million
dollars into renovating the Indianapolis
Motor Speedway the home in the Indy 500
in addition to that the series is
returning to old locations racetracks
that the series hasn't been at and
decade or two tracks have done a good
job in providing those other forms of
entertainment to allow people to be
interested in being at the event such as
at Indy you have the manufacturers
Midway the garages are opening along
with the fact of having entertainment
offerings with concerts so it's a
constantly evolving atmosphere for
promoters and stakeholders in the
industry that they have to stay with the
times and I think everybody is really
doing a great job to promote the sport
of racing in the United States and
around the world
the biggest thing miles needed to fix
was the TV when he took over the job he
was saddled with the television deal
that split races between ABC and NBC's
cable networks fans didn't know where to
watch you know any given weekend you
didn't know what network the race was
going to be on and jumping between the
networks meant that you weren't always
getting race to race promotion on those
TV channels I remember in my first
meeting with all the drivers I heard
from the veterans like Dixon and cañada
and others hey fix the TV we got a great
sport and a great product not enough
people are seeing and do more in the way
of promotion and get us in front of more
of course fans the sport itself the
competitive racing the excitement
compelling nature the racing has been
great I think it's gotten even better
but it was really a great start
the biggest move that miles has made was
to assign a new deal with NBC we're only
a few months into the first season of
this contract but it seems to be doing
really really well
ratings for the first four races of the
season were up more than 20 percent over
last year and most recently you're
seeing that that viewership trend of the
Daytona 500 versus Indy 500 potentially
starting to reverse Daytona's TV ratings
have been falling along with the rest of
NASCAR's races and the Indy 500 seems to
be on the verge of a comeback this year
viewership was up over last year and the
expectations are that you know with this
new TV deal in place that those numbers
will continue to rise I think there's
been a lot of growth just based on fan
viewership gaining a younger fan base
but it's all come through I think our
product that we put on the track of race
day so it's hard to say whether IndyCar
is never gonna get back to the heyday of
top auto sports seriese not only in the
country but maybe in the world however
this is the first time in more than two
decades Indy cars heading in the right
direction new owners are coming into the
sport
sponsors are coming back and most
importantly the fans are coming back and
so I think that for the first time in a
long time Indy cars where it really
wants to be
[Music]
you